[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi guys.
Soon it will be a new year.
And when the clock
strikes 12:00,
I want you to
become the new you.
What's she like?
I don't know.
I haven't seen her for
a really long time.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC PLAYING]
(ECHOING) Hey guys.
I'm Danielle Williams, founder
of Very, Very Vegetable.
Make sure to tune in.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey.
I'm so grateful you
invited me tonight.
[POPPING]
[GASPING]
[MUSIC BOX PLAYING]
Never have I ever bullied a
perfectly sweet, innocent girl
until she committed suicide.
[LIGHTNING CRACKS]
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
The world deserves
to know the truth.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
Come out Lex.
[SCREAMING]
[MUSIC STOPS]
[MUSIC BOX PLAYING]